a little chat about the division the
closed beta was on I was a 22 weeks ago
yes and there is a new one coming
Thursday februari 18 this thursday on
xbox one and then if you want to play
the not shitty looking version and you
can end up on AC like I'm so sorry my
cell phone it does not look good on xbox
one I'm just saying it does like that
much better on ps4 yeah you know the ps4
and PC versions at then this Friday a
day later febri 19th it's gonna run
until friend twenty first of the month
that's the sunday who knows though they
push the other one back a day so they
could do it again they've added
technicians I guess the tech is a sign
that way I don't win the closer then and
they're not big what is it like the the
big sort of area that you own there is
like it's divided up into various wings
and then the tech one was previously
closed so they're gonna yeah so new
missions I guess so you're probably
gonna save someone like you save someone
in the medical mission it's going to
open up its it'll open up some new
skills as well probably not too much
because in the closed beta you're only
really able to get I think to medical
skills and then kind of like perk one of
them but at least you'll get to do that
but yeah tech wing maybe there'll be a
third beta with the security wing she's
probably not though because the games
out I know yeah really cause only a
month to go ad they've also we talked a
lot about the dark zone a couple of
weeks ago and sort of how we work to
know it didn't work and it was like very
interesting sort of things at play there
but it didn't really feel like it was
clicking particularly right so they've
added a lot of sort of incremental
touches to it and there's new high-end
weapons available in there the refresh
rate on the chest has been greatly
reduced non-player enemies in the dark
zone have been significantly increased
in number and not their enemies and
didn't ducks on have also been buffed
slightly so they're doing a lot in
comparison to that stuff and then some
other bits and bobs the manhunt time
right now pauses instead of refreshing
when the combat is level 5 rogue so it's
all very like again yeah they're
definitely tinkering before release I
think dark zone is a major point of
interest for them because it seems like
you know that's gonna be I wouldn't
slick their main TV is actually
basically right I could I don't want to
guess but it could be end game 2 you
know you never know cuz all the best all
the best
are in there like I I'm curious if
you'll ever find a high-end gun in a
mission where I haven't seen one you
know I've seen blue drops and stuff like
that but haven't seen high end but yeah
it'll be interesting is I'm glad they're
populating the dark zone more because
you could run for a while or not yeah
anything about other people and then
everyone's kind of running to these
points of interests like the library or
like the the sports store where
everyone's trying to fight over the you
know whatever AI is there because that's
where you're gonna get your drops to
kind of get to get them out at the dark
zone extrac not yeah just felt like
players were having like they were
engaging with other players almost out
of boredom sometimes that it was like
yeah people were being way more
aggressive than they normally would
except there's no one else to shoot
someone [ __ ] it I might as well shoot
this yeah that's that especially cuz it
would like this hardly there's not
really that much if you haven't picked
anything up there's nothing stopping you
from just going in a tradition everyone
right yeah there's nothing yeah you're
not gonna lose anything it's definitely
another thing they're probably gonna
have to look at and like you said they
are tinkering the rogue system but going
rogue is fun especially like you say if
you have nothing to lose yeah well
you're always going to lose something
like you'll lose money and experience
but if you're not carrying any items and
you know what's to stop you from growing
road doing a game delaying the twitch
shots as devs have said that you can get
high-end weapons and missions but
they're significantly more likely to
drop in the DZ so they're just some
stuff in there yeah it should be
interesting i'm wondering what its gonna
be like when more people get involved
that was a closed beta before but did
seem a lot of people were in yeah it
seemed like i was like over watch where
it seems mostly like its price and
streamers and then some extra people but
it move it seemed like it was it yeah
there's a people there amount of people
in there it's hard to say because i
don't know if the dark zone areas if
they're locked to you know like almost
like server type things where there's
like 20 to 30 in this dark zone there's
another 20 to 30 in another dark zone
like you don't really have a greeeeat
it's not like destiny where you're in
the tower even though that technically
has an appt of people but you see you
know like 30 people look like that other
than that you see like strays here and
there you're like oh yeah hey bud you
doing the same mission I'm run in there
too I'm sure why you shooting me my uni
yeah um she'll be interesting to see
anyway if you're interested in getting
it you might want to start downloading
right now 27 cake
hey you can preload it you can you can
xbox one you can preload it on PC as
well oh nice I think so i'm pretty sure
okay cuz i'm already in there from the
previous beta so for me it's already of
its up there so tested it who knows or
you can just buy call of duty for
fifteen dollars and play multiplayer on
that for a while i think you get a good
i think you'll get a and a big enough
slice of kind of what the game is and
how it feels to at least know if you're
gonna want to buy it yes they do lock a
lot of the skills and stuff behind like
a way like you can't touch those and
that looks like the more in-depth stuff
but I mean a device like this and this
we talked about betas as demos like how
when we grow up with demos and cover
discs and downloads but like betas are
becoming so much more prevalent
obviously there is technical reasons why
they're doing this I mean the fact that
they've done all these changes to the
dark zone shows that but this really
feels like a game that like I didn't
know what this game was until I actually
played it for five minutes I was like oh
god like okay and then after like two or
three hours it was kind of like you get
the feel for it and so I think it'll it
could definitely help you if you if
you're going to play this game and not
enjoys you'll probably know pretty clear
I'm definitely so stuck kind of in the
middle how are you feeling about it I'm
interested for sure I want to see all
these other later skills and how that
changes things I want to know what like
when I hit 20 or what I think that's the
max level potentially uh you know what
is the end game like is it only the dark
zone in PvP or is there some kind of
almost like Ray desk type thing that's
what I'm more curious about the
mechanics the shooting mechanics are
fine the cover of mechanics are okay you
know what I mean it's because some
people have problems with like everyone
the chats talking about the you know
bein 122 and the house owner saying the
only thing I've seen of the game that
bothers me as I hate spongy enemies and
that was one of the things that like
made me go whoo straight away and
they're making a more spongy yeah are
separate yeah yeah so um it's it's I
don't know like when you snipe someone
in the head in theory right you should
be dead but yeah you know that's not how
video games to work so this video game
works oh yeah you just see a lot of
numbers kind of it's kind of like almost
like wow you're just like yeah then it
finally dies got em up yes I guess we'll
find out later on this week yeah let us
know if you are interesting thing to
beta imax
if you're watching this maybe on
gamespot of YouTube in a couple of days
time once the beta is live you've played
us let us know what you think and we'll
circle back to this bad boy on next
week's lobby